[MUSIC PLAYING]
STEREN GIANNINI: Hi.
I'm Steren.
KAROLINA NETOLICKÁ:
And I'm Karolina.
STEREN GIANNINI:
Today, we are going
to talk about how to run
your jobs on surveillance
with Cloud Run.
First, let me recap
what Cloud Run is.
Cloud Run allows you to
deploy and scale applications
fast and securely in a
fully managed environment.
Let's jump into a quick demo.
I will show you how easy
it is to deploy your Python
app to Cloud Run from
a GitHub repository.
From the Cloud Console, I
navigate to the Cloud Run page.
I create a service.
I select "Continuously deploy
from a source repository."
The panel opens where
I can connect to GitHub
and select one of
my Git repositories.
My repo is a Python application.
It doesn't include
any Docker file.
Cloud Run can build from sources
from many popular languages.
For the sake of the demo, I
will make my service public
by allowing unauthenticated
invocations.
And I click Deploy.
My code is built into a
container image by Cloud Build
and then will be
deployed to Cloud Run.
If we take a quick
look at the code,
we can see it is a standard
Python flask application.
I used a requirement
that takes the file
to declare my dependencies.
And there is no Docker file.
Once completed, I get a stable
and secure HTTPS endpoint
to invoke my service.
Cloud Run will start
as many instances
as needed to handle all incoming
traffic, including scale to 0.
Let's give it a try
by providing an image.
We can see that our
microservice has
transformed my picture of Half
Dome into a coloring book.
Nice.
Back into the user
interface, I can see which
Git commit is actually running.
When I push to my
Git repository,
my code will
automatically be built
and new revisions of this
service will be deployed.
I can see at the top a
build history at a glance.
I can see key metrics of my
service and my service's logs.
I can quickly edit
settings of my service,
like environment variables,
mounting Secrets,
connecting to Cloud SQL.
Let's select More
Memory in order
to be able to process
bigger images.
By default, these new
settings will roll out
as soon as I click Deploy.
But let's do something different
and not serve this new revision
immediately.
Once deployed, this new revision
is serving 0% of the traffic.
I can test it using a
dedicated URL endpoint.
And then I can gradually
roll out traffic
to it-- let's say 10%.
If anything goes wrong,
I can always roll back
to a previous revision.
So hopefully, this
demo shows you
how easy it is to deploy
an app from a GitHub repo
to Cloud Run.
Cloud Run allows you to
deploy and scale applications
fast and securely in a
fully managed environment.
As you've seen, it is
simple and automated.
You have no infrastructure
to provision in advance,
no cluster to manage.
And it allows you to be more
productive, to move faster.
So when should
you use Cloud Run?
We identified three
big categories--
first, websites and APIs.
This goes from traditional
server-side rendered web pages
to REST or GraphQL APIs.
But Cloud Run also has built-in
support for web sockets,
allowing you to stream data
between front end and back end.
Then private
services-- for example,
you can put a website behind
an authentication page
with Google Cloud
Identity-Aware Proxy.
You can build private
microservice-to-microservice
architectures, either
over HTP or gRPC.
And last, data processing--
Cloud Run services can be
invoked by Cloud Pub/Sub,
can receive tasks
from Cloud Tasks,
and receive events
from Eventarc.
Cloud Run automatically
scales the number of instances
of your code, even down to 0.
If your app suddenly
gets a burst of traffic,
there is nothing to worry about.
Cloud Run will scale fast to
handle all incoming requests.
And when fewer
instances are needed,
Cloud Run will automatically
reduce their number down to 0
if no traffic is
received after a while.
But how is Cloud Run priced?
Well, first, Cloud
Run has a free tier.
Each month, you get
2 million requests
available at no charge.
Then Cloud Run truly
is pay per views.
You pay for the exact CPU and
memory used by your services
when they are
processing requests
with 100-millisecond
granularity.
That means that there is no
charge if it's not in use.
As we've seen, we can deploy
source code written in Node.js,
Python, Go, .Net,
Kotlin, Scala, Java,
and any other language
via containers.
Container images are,
basically, like a ZIP file.
They allow you to
package everything
that's needed to run your code.
This, of course, includes
its language packages,
but also any native
libraries or custom
binaries that you would need.
And finally, I want to highlight
how Cloud Run integrates
with Firebase.
Your code on Cloud Run can
query data from Firestore
or use Firebase
clients or admin SDKs.
But you can also
use Firebase Hosting
in front of your
Cloud Run service
in order to host
static files or assets,
to cache your HTTP requests
using the cache control header,
or to easily set up
your own custom domain.
And now let's hear
from Karolina.
KAROLINA NETOLICKÁ: So now that
we've learned about Cloud Run,
let's talk about Cloud Run jobs.
Imagine you're using Cloud
Run to run an e-commerce site
and it's working great.
Cloud run is autoscaling
your service to meet demand.
You're really happy
that you don't need
to manage any infrastructure.
And your developer
velocity has gone up.
But you find yourself
with pieces of work
that don't fit neatly into
any Cloud Run service.
For example, your
suppliers send you
invoices that you need to
periodically process and pay.
You could write a web
service that does this task.
But what you'd really like
to do is write a script
to process all these
invoices and then
run the script as a cron job.
This is where Cloud
Run jobs come in.
Cloud Run jobs are a new feature
of Cloud Run that we just
announced here at
I/O. Cloud Run jobs
let you run scripts and data
processing jobs in Cloud Run
right alongside your services.
This means that you get to
benefit from Cloud Run's
simple integration with the rest
of the Google Cloud ecosystem,
including Secret Manager
and fine-grained IAM.
Cloud Run also works with
many common storage systems.
So you have flexibility
on where to store any data
that your job is processing.
What's unique about
Cloud Run jobs
is that they start up
much faster than starting
a VM to run a script on.
In fact, many jobs start running
in as little as 10 seconds.
If your workload
is parallelizable,
you can further speed it
up by splitting your work
into multiple
tasks, each of which
handles a subset of your input.
Between the fast startup
and running in parallel,
Cloud Run jobs work
particularly well for situations
where you need jobs
to complete quickly--
for example, because there's a
person waiting for the result.
So what are Cloud
Run jobs useful for?
First, they're a great match
for scheduled scripts, things
like nightly reports, database
maintenance, and audit scripts.
You can run these
scripts on a schedule
by using Cloud Scheduler.
Cloud Run jobs are also great
for background processing,
where some user
interaction has resulted
in offline work that needs to
be done in the background--
for example, sending
email campaigns for
abandoned shopping carts or
running web testing suites.
Finally, you can use Cloud Run
jobs for batch data processing.
So let's go back to our previous
example of processing invoices.
I'm going to show you
how you can use Cloud Run
jobs to process these
invoices using Document AI
and to store the parsed
data in Firestore.
To speed up processing,
we'll run the job
with eight parallel
tasks, each of which
will process a subset
of the invoices.
We'll also show a
simple web service
that lets us review
the processed invoices
and approve them for payment.
Here's the Cloud Storage bucket
where our invoices are stored.
New ones come in
every day and are
placed in a folder called
Incoming to indicate that they
haven't been processed.
Right now, this folder
has a few dozen invoices
waiting to be processed
the next time the job runs.
Let's take a look
at a few of them.
You can see that these are
designed for humans to look at
rather than to be
machine-readable.
Here's the code we'll use
to process these invoices.
The code loops through the
contents of the storage bucket.
First, it skips any
invoice that will
be handled by a different task.
Each running task is
aware of its task index.
So it can look up which file
name prefixes it is responsible
for versus other tasks
are responsible for
and decide whether
to skip or process
this particular invoice.
It also skips anything
that looks like a folder.
Then it calls
Document AI to extract
the invoice data, such as
vendor names and totals.
And it saves that
information to Firestore.
Finally, it moves the
invoice to a different folder
so that it won't
be processed again
the next time the job is run.
Now let's build a container.
I'm going to use Cloud
Build from the command line
to create the container and
save it to a repository.
Now I'll create
my Cloud Run job.
I'll specify the image to
run, the region to run in,
the number of tasks, and a
few environment variables
that the container needs.
And I have a job.
Let's take a look at my list
of jobs in the Cloud Console.
There it is.
I'm going to click Execute.
And here's my job running.
I'm going to click on
it to get more details.
The progress bar
at the top is going
to update as tasks
start and finish.
While we're waiting for
the job to complete,
let's take a quick
look at the logs.
You can see the debugging
messages right here.
So you don't have
to navigate away.
The job succeeded.
Let's take a look at the output.
The data that's been pulled
out from these invoices
has been saved in Firestore.
We see here that we have
a collection of invoices.
And for each invoice, we can
see the amount, the company it's
from, the due date, and so on.
And to make it
even easier to see,
here's a simple web page hosted
as a Cloud Run service that
lets you review the
processed invoices
and select whether to
approve them for payment.
Finally, we want this
job to run every night.
Cloud Scheduler is
perfect for this.
I'll give Cloud Scheduler
a name and a region.
I'm going to run my job
at 1:00 AM every night.
My Cloud Run job will be
triggered via an HTTP request
through the Cloud Run admin API.
You can find the URL
in the documentation.
As the last step, I'll give
Cloud Scheduler permissions
to start the Cloud Run job.
The Scheduler trigger is ready.
It will run tonight.
But let's test it once.
I'll click Run Now.
And then I'll go take
a look at my job.
I see a new execution
has already started.
And I already have
tasks running.
So let's recap what
I've shown you here.
I built and deployed a Cloud
Run job, which loads invoices
from Cloud Storage, calls
Document AI to analyze them,
and stores the parsed
invoice data in Firestore.
My job runs every night.
And we have a nice interface for
our team to approve invoices.
And at the end of all of this,
we have no VMs or clusters
that we need to manage.
And we only pay when our
services or jobs are actually
running.
So to summarize
it all, Cloud Run
lets you run your containers
in a fully managed environment
so that we take care of
infrastructure management
and you focus on
your business logic.
Use Cloud Run services for
web services and Cloud Run
jobs for containers
that run to completion,
such as scripts and
data processing jobs.
STEREN GIANNINI: Cloud
Run is a simpler way
to deploy your web services--
KAROLINA NETOLICKÁ:
--and your jobs.
STEREN GIANNINI: Go check them
out at cloud.google.com/run.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]